SENIOR SURVIRSWITH THAT S IS AD
ND, DU FS OF HIGH SCHOOLTOYOU S
A  EES SURVIVORS ARE
SET IN THEIREXAPTER.OM S
>>HER S
STUDENT.FOR  SCHOO
RISON.OVE YOU TOO.
I'
>>
>> YEAH. NOW.
>> BUT FOR TS GRTI
T
HIGH SCHOOHAS BEEN.
>> SHOOTING >> STONEMAN DOUGLAS.
ACTIVE S
>> I IG IS WHERE THE SHOOTING
HAPPENED.
THE FST FLOOR IN ROOM
OKE WAS 14-YEAR-OLD
HMAN AT MARJORIE STOWEMAN
DO SCHOOPARKLAND,WAOL SHOOTINGS
HEL EDN MY CLASSROOM
ME DECIDEDSHOTY CLASSROOM.D SOOA
TO HWAS THT LLED.
YOU.GE
FRESHMAN UR
THE AL.
D THEN THE RES KIND OF
>>S THE WORST
MENTAHEALSEM NG EVERYTHING I
>> THAT WAS THE'S OGIDED THEY HV
LII HATESCFTER U ALW SCHOOL? LI
SHOOTING.GLS WAS KE
IN
SO MUCH HAPPENED THAT IT FEELS
LIKE I'VE BE LIN DOG
AR --
>> REALLY?
HIGH SCHOOL  Y.
I TELL PEOPL TIME
WHENHE I FEET GRADUATING.
>> Reporter: AND IN TH
THEY'VE
>> I'M 14.
SCHOOL.N'T HAO THINK ABOUT
>> Reporter: STARTA MOVEMENT
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE
GONE GLOBAL TH MARCH FOR
LIVES.
TEENS TAKING ON ONOF THE
INTRACTABLE POLITICAGH
A CRISIS THAT'S  G
WORSE.
MORE THAN 150SHOOTIS G
THIS YEAR.Y NUMBW OUTDATED.
>>EAeporter: PEO
SAYI I
NYTHING, YOUIN.
>> YEAH. WHAT YOU'RE GOINGO SAY
THE SHOOTING I THOT THE
STORY.S ST. AS A CHILD,ED TTHAT.
OT
WO MD I REALIZED I
DO. THAT TDON' WHAT TO
THEY CHOOSE NOT TO.eporter:NDT T
SCHOOL YEARS.SINCE E BEENITY R.
>> IT'S BE
ITNG ELSE
GOIND, IT IT'S
COMPOUNDED OUR TRAUMA AND THE
T'R MAKES
I  FRIENDS.
JUST DN'T T THE
REGULAR JOHNUGOU KNOW,
>> HE HOOL?F.
E.IT EXAM.S BEDROOM SCFISANK
>> EVERYTH
>> IT'S LIKE AN
SHE'S BEEN IN MY HOUSE THE
SOUAEEN SO GME AS MUCH AON SO M.
EGREALRSI WIVEALI WIT N FFERENS
THAT THEIR KID FRO
GROW UP.EY BEEN ABLERADUATE ANDN
Y S HARD
MOMENTS ALREADY INSE YOUGIRLS' T
WHAT DOES THIST T ST
>> IT DOESL KER E A eporter: DO?
>>D OFYEAH.
FEELS LIKE AHANCE  OL
eporter: YOU HAVE ALLOT
THIS POINT I YOU'RE
EADY TO G
BECAUSE I THIF I
FORWARD WITHOUT REFLECTING
I'VE ALL
HAPPEN.AUREN IS SUNDECIDED D
WHAT SHE WANTS TO UD
COEGE.
D T
D S TO NALISM.
I HAVE TO SAY, I THINK
I'MET TWO  I'M
MORE EXCITEDD WINGE ANOL THE NE.
HIGH SCHOOL  I TE SHOE IN THIUNU
SAID, WITHNERMD  TNEE ERE KILLE
THE TOINUE TILHA
TO CHANGE THE DEBATE
CHANGESOT FRES OFF AND DO WHATER
FULL O WHOSE LIVL OFS A -- AEAIS
HE SAME.
AND FOTHE FAMILIESNE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO OUGHTBE